foreign
[Music]
thank you for participating in this
webinar my name is Anthony I'm field
application specialist of the nexgen PCR
at molecular ability systems and in this
presentation I will share new data and
knowledge about accelerating monkey box
and source code 2 sequencing for our
whole genome sequencing using next-gen
PCR and nanopore sequencing which will
allow to go towards more real-time
genomic surveillance and that's also
something that the World Health
Organization States because the global
genomic surveying strategy for petitions
includes generating genomic data
data that is actually generated in your
laboratory which has an impact on how we
deal viruses because the generated data
will be aligned to on-cloud analyzes to
search for similarities and differences
this data is then used
to monitor the disease daily Public
Health interventions develop medicines
and vaccines and in order to stop
outbreaks or eradicate diseases
the aim of this presentation is mainly
focused on how we can actually improve
the generating of genomic data whereby
we actually use Search Group 2
sequencing as an example we can actually
strengthen the goal of the world's World
Health Organization whereby these days
to strengthen genomic surveillance and
have a more skilled quality And Timely
appropriate Public Health actions within
local to Global surveillance systems
so if we take a closer look at sargof2
sequencing at the moment we actually see
two main protocols that are used so we
also we have the Arctic protocol from
George quick which used 99 amplicons
which are which are around 400 base
pairs and we have the midnight protocol
from Nikki freed
and I will in Sri London where they used
around 29 to 30 amplicons which are
around 1200 base perch
we choose to optimize the midnight
protocol and that's mainly because the
reduced numbers of amplicons in the
midnight protocol allows for more
consistent sequencing across the whole
genome and thereby the the annealing of
the requirements is just 4.5 percent of
the whole genome which decreases the
chance for any viral mutations in the
primary binding sites
um which lowers the chance that we have
to exchange the primers or put in an
additional update in the primary set
and if we take even a closer look at the
midnight protocol we see it's actually
divided in different kinds of steps so
we have the cdna which takes around 20
minutes we have the amplification steps
we take four hours we have to wrap it
barcoding and then we have the library
prep for nanopore sequencing
the total Library prep from sample
before it goes into the nanopore
sequencer takes around five and a five
and a half hours
and that's quite long especially if
you're getting samples which are Urgent
in the midday so we actually looked into
this workflow and what would be the main
bottleneck and what we actually saw is
that using our technology we can
actually decrease the PCR time from four
hours maybe to less than 30 minutes
which really has an impact on how
Laboratories are using
their resources
because if we
look at the workflow and we have the
conventional Library prep which takes
around 5 hours and three and a half
hours to four hours PCR
you are already taking the whole day
before you can start with the Nana
prosequencing and depending on the
amount of samples you are using a
nanoprosecusing can take up to two hours
but also slightly longer if we decrease
the PCR time from three and a half hours
to less than 30 minutes we can have a
sample prep from one half to two hours
which allows you to get faster
sequencing data
increased throughput because you can do
more runs on a single day but the main
benefit would be lab flexibility which
means that even if you get your samples
in the midday you can still process them
the same day which allows you to get
faster sequencing data and that's
actually what we did in our laboratory
in collaboration with Amsterdam
University Medical Center and Avance
University of applied science We
performed first experiments on an
arcosity gel using our 27 minute this
year and used optimized a picture Mouse
muscle mixes for our next PCR
in search way that we could decrease the
annealing and the extension using our
Nexium PCR and if we look at the across
gel here on the right side we even get
clear amplification even at 10 copies
per microliter
however we first experiments they are
performed using synthetic RNA
um
so we really have to test it on clinical
samples and perform sequencing to
understand the genome coverage of all
the different amplicons and if this is
sufficient
and that is actually what we did at
Amsterdam University Medical Center We
performed a small experiment on clinical
samples with three different CT values
20 CTV 20.93
28.46 NCT value 30.49
and we actually compared our data from
an action PCR which you can see in this
graph in blue with the conventional PCR
and the conventional
workflow which is used for the midnight
protocol
and what we can actually see is that
using the faster PCR the 27 minute PCR
we did get uniform coverage of the whole
genome and similar to the conventional
PCR
which is also seen when we look at the
whole coverage of the charge of 2 genome
using the 27 minute PCR we obtained more
than 99
genome coverage of the whole genome of
charge curve 2 which was even slightly
higher than the conventional PCR system
where we had a few
below 99 coverage
at least we can say because it's quite a
small sample set we can actually say
that using the fast PCR it will not be
less than conventional PCR
however we wanted to test this workflow
on more clinical samples however during
this time the world faced a monkey box
outbreak worldwide
and therefore we actually shift our
priorities
um to Monkey box sequencing
and that was also mainly because in the
region of Amsterdam there required a lot
of cases and what we discussed in the
beginning we wanted to have sequencing
methods and generate genomic data of
monkeypox
which are not which are scalable have
high quality and give file sequencing
data
so that's actually where we were looking
into because the methods that were used
for monkeypox sequencing were mainly
metagenomics
of course it was working but the
corporate was quite low which allows you
to multiply less samples on a single
flow cell which is increasing the cost
so therefore we thought well what if we
can use PCR tiling for monkeypox based
on the knowledge from the midnight
protocol and the shark of two sequencing
from Nikki Fritz
and they're actually we collaborated
again with Amsterdam University Medical
Center and also with Martin's how
Peterson from the Rex Hospital in
Copenhagen
in order to develop a next-gen PCR
tiling approach
um which will give faster timely and
higher throughput sequencing data and
this was actually more an outbreak
setting because monkeypox was actually
spreading there was not that many data
about monkeypox and we could directly
apply it in the region of Amsterdam
because they are relatively a high
amount of cases
and this way we expect to increase the
coverage and even to decrease the cost
because we can Multiplex multiple
samples from a single flow cell so there
we actually started using a
amplicomb-based sequencing method for
monkeypox which is on one side easier
and on the other side harder than search
of 2. because monkeypox you don't have
to do the reverse transcription because
it's DNA however monkey pops It's 190 or
over 190 KB long which is substantially
longer than sarskov 2. so Marcus how
Peterson he developed 88 primer sets
which can be divided over two pools and
each pool
has 44 primer sets these were developed
by using the Primal skin
and the average amplical size was 2.5 KB
and we had an overlap of 200 base perch
between the different amplicons and for
this we used a 42 minute PCR protocol
using our Nexium PCR
the bioinformatic analysis that is used
um
the it's used we used Min no software
high accuracy live based calling we
removed the read length below one on
base first and above 4000 base per from
the first Q file and then we use the
first Cube raw data in order to map it
to the monkey block USA 2020
ma001 using minimap V2
we remove a map reads using Sam tools
and we generate corporate's preposition
using same sets V 1.12
so we actually generated consensus using
three common sense package from the rvm
and we used pilot we made a palogenetic
analysis using next-ring mongerbox
builds
so if we looked at the data
we actually uh we shall we first
optimized with a few different PCR
settings and then we could get our data
within three days
and what we actually saw in this data is
that we already obtained really high
coverage
depth Incorporated genome coverage in
general so if we look at ctvr 20 we have
over 99 a genome coverage and even at
cctv22 we have saw the same however at
gt526 and cctv29 we saw that the
coverage was coming a little bit more
down whereby there were three different
sites where the coverage was mostly
dropping quite low or below the 10 times
coverage depth
um however the data was actually quite
amazing because we could actually
amplify the whole genome of monkeypox
within 42 minutes which is quite amazing
because it's 190 KB and the data that is
generated was sufficient to test a total
of 40 clinical samples in the region of
Amsterdam and this data of the 40
samples was really helpful to understand
the spread of monkeypox even more which
actually resulted into a newer
surveillance rapid communication paper
where they looked into a case
um because there was a child with an
unknown source of infections in the
Netherlands and they didn't understand
how these shells could have been
infected
even contact racing and testing of
parents of people who were in contact
with the child did not give any clear
data
and the sequencing data of the 40
samples
in the region of Amsterdam were put into
the phylogenetic tree and in red here on
the right side you can see the child and
it's actually plotted through the older
40 postage samples
and also the sequencing data actually
showed there was no direct links between
the 40 samples in the region of
Amsterdam and the child
and actually showing
that there could be even or indicating
there is more spreads in the population
than only within the MSM Community which
we was known at the beginning of the
outbreaks which is really knowledgeable
data which is important to guide Public
Health interventions
we try to optimize this workflow even
slightly a little bit further by
increasing the primary regions of the
parameter 22 29 and 50 because there we
saw three regions with lower coverage
however using the next mpcr we did not
obtain a higher coverage we even saw
more imbalancing of the sequencing data
using the conventional PCR it has an
effect so there we saw that for those
three regions we did get a higher room
and better coverage
so in in general
we can actually say that
sarcoph2
or based on this data and the
presentation we can actually state that
search of 2 can be Amplified or the
whole genome can be Amplified using a 27
minute PCR program with an action PCR
for monkeypox we can use a PCR title
which is a really feasible and
increasing the quality of your data in
order to get better data and you can
even amplify it within 42 minutes and
with the conventional PCR it will take
three and a half hours however what we
see in the data is that we get lower
coverage in three different regions so
29 22 and premise at 50.
where we're still looking into how to
optimize this because if we get even
higher coverage and more uniform
coverage it also means that we can
Multiplex even more samples in the
single flow cell and decreasing the cost
even further
so with this new workflow using Nexium
PCR we can really accelerate genomic
surveillance worldwide improve Public
Health interventions
and this is also a good fundamental for
other
applications because if you can imagine
that you can amplify 190 KB you can
actually amplify
every virus or every pathogen that you
want using a PCR tiling
and the reverse offense paper also shows
the impacts of getting those faster
sequencing data which will be vital in
managing
managing pathogens in general
and which is actually
yeah increasing better surveillance so
better genomic sequencing others is to
understand and monitor viruses and
Target our Disease Control more
accurately
before the end of the presentations I
would like to thank and acknowledge MBS
as our company Avant University of
applied science Amsterdam University
Medical Center the Rex Hospital in
Copenhagen and the public health in
Amsterdam of the region of Amsterdam
thank you very much for this
presentation and if you have any
questions you can always send us an
email or give aggression in the chat
thank you